hello garans today we're going to be
talking about the irregular plural uh
previously I had said that if you take
any English word any noun say the word
dog and you tack an S onto the end of it
like so Boop you get the word dogs and
that's how you form the plural uh in all
cases I was lying sorry um it turns out
that English is a little bit more
complicated than that while adding an S
to things is the way you usually make
things plural sometimes there are other
changes and sometimes you don't even
pluralize using an S at the end but
we're not going to talk about that now
that's for another time what I want to
talk about today is the most basic kind
of irregular plural so we have the
difference in English between
regular and irregular
plurals and remember a plural uh is when
there's more than one of something it
comes from the Latin plus which means
more as opposed to the singular when
there is just one of
something you know one one dog two dogs
so there's a handful of words in English
and it really is a handful that don't
pluralize
regularly words like leaf and
Loaf and calf it's a baby cow if you try
to pluralize these as though they were
regular plurals you're going to return
something that is
not correct or at least is not
conventional within Modern Standard
American English right so Leafs for
example unless you're talking about the
Toronto hockey team is not correct in
fact the proper term boop boop boop boop
boop boop is in fact
leaves it is not loaves but loaves tasty
loaves of bread it is not calfs but
calv so there are several different
kinds of irregular plurals that's why
this video is called part one but I'm
only going to cover one such irregular
plural today and that is the change from
singular F to plural
V an important caveat an important
exception here is double F words like
Cliff or sheriff or sniff do not change
to ve or V in the plural they become
Cliffs sheriffs sniffs there are
exceptions to that too right like staff
to staves but for the most part double F
doesn't change to ve single F mostly
does right that's the general rule
singular word ends in F the plural will
be v s Leaf to leaves loaf to loaves
calf to calves generally for the most
part English ah so silly who's driving
this thing we love it though you can
learn anything Dave it
out